[Musique]
nouvelle fournée qui commandera des
gastros nous emmène voir une boîte
française ou vote de grenoble qui est en
passe de révolutionner une partie là du
tri du smartphone vous c'est gratuit et
vraiment brillé
hop
très bien on est donc sur le stand up to
you hate you j'en ai déjà parlé
plusieurs fois notamment aux crs l'année
dernière qu'est ce que tu veux que je
dise
rien aux crs il y a deux ans y investir
je vois souvent tout hiatus est une
entreprise de grenoble qui développe une
solution de toucher à petit alors
touche-à-tout qu'est-ce que tu te situer
rapidement ce que c'est
concrètement ça va être de pouvoir
générer des sensations de coucher sur
nos écrans et des quotas voilà situation
touche et sur les réponses sur les
écrans et les interfaces tactiles qu'on
a déjà au quotidien
tu vas avoir une surface ça d'avoir dû
être un écran et un écran vert donc qui
complètement lisse
je crois par exemple
smartphone s'assied lis je le touche jeu
sans rien renier de guerre ok je sors du
der et qu'est ce que vous allez vous
créer avec ça mais où on va envoyer une
un ultrason dans l'écran et vous passez
de générer une section détection peut
avoir un prix se passe est large
on adore le faire avec un poisson nous
rapporte
ressentir des écailles du poisson du
sang les arguments en tout genre oui
l'agrément et même de manière dynamique
donc si tu va dans le bon sens ces
listes itunes va rebooster cagnes où est
votre intérêt à entretenir le doigt ok
donc ça c'est vraiment l'idée du touch
haptique vous créez une déformation
toutes deux équipes c'est ça on va en
voir en génère un ultrason dans leur
façon de l'espace de l'écran et quand je
vais toucher je vais sentir ce que je
vois mon écran exactement
j'ai regardé clair avec un croissant
d'équipements des prêts moins de les
tester donc canton s'étaient déjà
rencontrés on avait parlé que population
du verre vous avez aussi une solution 8
surface tout à fait encore officiel
casseurs du bois du métal du plastique
la plupart des surfaces rigides hockey
est donc là vous aller encore plus loin
et c'est là où on arrive dans les sujets
dans lequel je parle beaucoup et
notamment dans l'univers du smartphone
exactement
pour la première fois on a réussi à
intégrer notre technologie sur le form
factor d'un téléphone moi j'aime sur une
épaisseur extrêmement film
en fait jusqu'à maintenant une solution
à l'opposé de mm c'est à dire quand ça
marche et ça faisait deux mines
on a besoin d'ajouter de la matière de
mm et matière sur l'écran aspres un
endroit tu n'es pas sa tasse sous
l'écran en fait ouais soul exactement
mais collé sur l'écran ne pas pierre qui
vais envoyer notre ultrasons hockey et 2
mm c'est quand même plutôt fins et du
coup on industrialise dans d'autres
univers
cette solution mais pour le smartphone
de mm c'est injouable well as cette
année on le fait avec une solution à
deux mythes de migros deux micros donc
en fait c'est invisible si tu veux rien
d'un menu et ses imprimés directement
sur le verbe s'est imprimée sur le verre
ou soulever recettes possibles par sous
l'écran même s'ils jouent les vacances
qu'on appelle le stack mais ce que ça
vient un peu technique en séance un
petit peu là devant nous confier vos
toiles et feront quelque chose qui fait
2 microns qui doit se positionner au
niveau de ton de crottes permet d'avoir
une sensation de déformation en écoutant
des contacts e manquaient donc les
visages c'est quoi la presse qu'on en
fait ça par les usages c'est de
retrouver un petit peu tout le retour de
clichés qu'on a qu'on aimerait avoir à
la place d'avoir juste du verre donc tu
as peut être ya plusieurs taxes ça peut
être juste ludique sur du gaming où je
vais avoir mon petit kit effets de
texture sur mon jeu la pression sur ma
corde comme jouer à angry birds ce genre
de choses ça peut être de la précision
quand je joue quand je fais de la
molette quand je scroll sur un de mes
menus je ressens mieux ce qui se passe
parce que j'ai une texture qui va
vraiment sentir ce que tu vaux en fait
exactement je laisse au tournoi tu le
saurais m'en qui comprennent exactement
le plus simple est encore de faire
d'écran
comme on les aurait sur un menu ou sur
une sera sur un cahier mais là on est
donc là je vois c'est mon petit poisson
là j'ai vraiment lassant si vous faites
voilà des formations et j'ai la
sensation des écailles sous le doigt ce
que vous voyez bougez vous c'est ce que
moi je ressens sous le doigt de les
cayes de partout ça c'est la déformation
ultrasonique et c'est assez incroyable
de dire qu'en fait ce que je touche je
n'existe pas quoi lorsque je viens pour
passer un coup de fil donc là j'ai une
sensation soul dois je sens le comme si
je clique sur quelque chose
j'ai vraiment la sensation du clic bon
je vais taper mon numéro de téléphone
parce que j'ai pas vous appeliez mais
croyez-moi quand même des messages en
commentaire ça fait toujours plaisir
donc ça c'est ça lorsque je vais ici
j'ai h les jets claudio comment vous
avez choisi les noms là ça c'est
incroyable sais pas comment et là j'ai
une sensation effectivement ça fait clac
clac clac clac clac clac se sent
vraiment en fait quand ça bouge ensemble
ce sont là le tacle clac clac c'est
toujours très difficile à expliquer la
le ressenti comme ça mais se sent
vraiment l'avancé de par chaque nom tak
tak ensuite j'ai ici toute la partie un
peu gaming avec un jour je viens coupé
en fait hop
et quand je coupe ça me fait une
vibration passe pas une vibration c'est
une déformation et je sens que j'ai
coupé quand je le fais à côté rien du
tout une fois qu'ils étaient coupées là
je sens plus rien mais au moment où je
le coup je sens vraiment le comme un
petit hack dans mon doigt
ça c'est assez marrant parce que pour le
coup ça donne plus de réalisme alors bon
on est sur un petit jeu on coupe les
vannes à l'intention va pas se mentir
mais ça doit quand même vachement plus
de réalisme et dynamique objets comme ça
c'est cool
là par exemple je suis sur mon alarme
venir calais madame je sens fait là le
tac le bouton qui bouge
je le sens saint phalle espèce de deux
touchés se doit sa fait un tacle lorsque
j'appuie là je sens le clic de la même
manière et là je sens les différentes
heures défiler sous mes doigts ça me
fait un peu pareil la même sensation
le petit tac tac tac tac tac je sens les
minutes défiler et du coup ça paraît
quand même vachement plus intuitif
j'ai entendu mon doigt bouge alors qu'en
fait absolument pas là je peux avancer
dans ma vidéo c'est pareil à chaque fois
que j'ai une seconde je le sens où l'on
doit je me sens vraiment de la matière
c'est assez dingue pareil là je peux
bien remonté la luminosité donc plus je
montre ma plus je le sens où l'on doit
pareil quand je descends quand je vais
doucement ça me fait un par un c'est
complètement dingue
et là c'est pareil au niveau du volume
bon par contre l'approché ma femme est
une vidéo de me suivre quand même moins
pour faire là pour faire la démo mais ça
c'est dans ces matches beaucoup les
grands axes du smartphone est là où il
ya le plus d'innovations c'est aussi
tout ce qui est lié au retail donc à la
vente en ligne
ouais
gaming dont je viens de parler et pour
le retail faut bien imaginer que parents
pourquoi être sur une page pour acheter
des vêtements on va pour avoir une
texture qui va accompagner mon visuel
pour nice n'aura jamais la texture pas à
100% mais comme pour le poisson on va
faire un petit peu le cerveau est arrivé
à y croire comment tu fais ça je sais
pas vous par exemple que tu vas voir une
texture avec un spread de broc au thau
blake enfin ouais tu as une robe en soie
moi j'aime me promener dessus j'ai mon
visuel j'ai déjà ce qui va j'ai
aujourd'hui gère en plus ma texture
douce qui va accompagner le tout si je
veux avoir un pull en laine se voir
quelque chose un peu émaillé et voilà
après j'ai plus qu'à explorer il ya un
monde de r & d affaires et de recherche
dans l' usage c'est énorme et le champ
des possibles en termes de textures il
est extrêmement large et donc là tu me
parles de ça en terme d'usagé le gaming
le côté hérité pour l'avant et pour
pouvoir effectivement toucher les
touches et les textures du ski ergonomie
ouais donc pour le sport et ce genre de
choses et même pour l'accessibilité aux
malvoyants
on va pas faire du braille ce peut être
une idée intéressante mais on n'en est
pas encore là
par contre on pourrait déjà faire des
google matt où je vais ressentir mais
direction
vais sentir que j'avais tout droit à
deux reprises une texture qui va changer
pour que je parte soit à gauche ou à
droite et en explorant juste avec ma
manche pourrait le faire ça doit être
pour les malvoyants ça peut être si je
veux juste changé la musique quand je
suis dans le métro et que je suis serré
et que je
je peux pas regarder mon écran je peux
le faire dans ma poche je ne
s'inscrivent pas se tourner quand tu
touches tu le sens où exactement
ok ça sera donc 100 millions oui la
préoccupe bien sûr hockey des géniales
nos candidats fraîchement de saut on
pourrait même lui vers l'écran est en
fête et croate
écran éteint et donc à tous le montre et
à une application en fait tu as une
vidéo tu veux monte ça monte et la
luminosité c'est sur la partie gauche tu
mens tu sens vraiment way et tu manques
l'écran vraie leçon de l'autre côté
c'est pareil sur les tracts de la cyber
gonnot mis vraiment en général c'est
c'est plus avoir à polluer l'écran avec
des contrôles qu'on n'a pas envie de
voir pas de me regarder une vidéo
j'ai pas envie que tout mon écran
s'assombrissent pour avoir les contrôles
au niveau de volumes ce genre de choses
là tout se passe entre moi et m'ont
touchée et que c'est plus intime ça
marche mieux et comme ça mais les yeux
reste concentré sur ce que j'ai envie de
voir du coup là sur le smartphone vous
ouvrez le champ des possibles et vous
apporte une nouvelle dimension au niveau
de ce qu'on a sur smartphone vous avez
aussi un grand chose mais où est ce que
vous avez toujours nous par rapport à ça
parce que là vous présenté sur le stand
smartphones où on a effectivement le
toucher on voit des usages
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est
ce qui arrive ensuite pour vous là
dessus pour nous aujourd'hui le but du
jeu c'est de continuer à travailler avec
les géants du smartphone désensibiliser
de leur montrer notre champ des
possibles et leur donner envie
d'investir là dedans
pour eux c'est génial il aime déjà
beaucoup mais sait on
on parle de tous les plus grands géants
donc des techno incroyable il en
découvre sans parents donc à nous de
leur prouver que c'est celle là les gens
auront envie de voir après c'est là où
nous on en est convaincu le sait qu'on
le voit sur des salons comme ça tout le
monde tout le monde trouve ça tout
montré wang présence sur l'île pour le
coup au service des effets mais pas
partout mais ça s'est vraiment bien
parce que ça fait quelque chose d'hyper
novateur qui perd novateur je sens
vraiment cool alors du coup il ya cette
partie là est ce qu il yad autres partis
qui sont en train de se développer
aujourd'hui pour abdou on avance
beaucoup l'industrialisation dans
l'automobile ouais faut être conscient
besoin qui est des traits exprimé dans
l'automobile des écrans qui sont plus en
plus grand mais on
on a du mal à les contrôler en
conduisant ok c'est toujours un peu
gênant de voir regarder un écran soit
reconduit leur mouvement dont je
reconnais d'accord et donc forcément de
pouvoir ressentir ce qui se passe sur
ton écran dans le couchant
c'est hyper intéressant qu'on avance
break mercedes là dessus l'accord
sont déjà au capital de l'entreprise ok
go c'est génial on
techno contre l'autre au nom des futures
mères se laisse encore aujourd'hui
parlons aujourd'hui notre industrie
d'accord dans le matin des [ __ ] par
rapport à certains des gens au peut pas
attendre ne pas trop en parler
sa formule magique dans l'automobile
premium chez mercedes ouais tu toucheras
qui aura dû toucher atik exactement pour
la techno à pile ou dans les dents les
écrans c'est incroyable on est bientôt
dans race au fil du match
donc dans la voiture après on n'est plus
obligé de limiter aux écrans on peut le
faire dans des volumes on peut le faire
dans d'autres matières on pourra
directement art du contrôle revient dans
le volant pourquoi pas directement dans
la fenêtre dans la portière il ya un
champ des possibles à ces vous d'accord
ça c'est une super vitrine pour vous
bien sûr ces montres effectivement raté
la voiture voilà notre technologie et on
peut la mettre où ouais c'est ça qu'est
donc en automobile en avance très fort
maintenant on essaye aussi d' invincible
pour l'électroménager
toutes les machines avec écran qu'on a
chez nous ou pas encore mais machine à
café avec des fours on part avoir
supprimé les boutons mécaniques physique
on a un droit qui va venir tourner comme
ça tu sentiras exactement est comme ça
tu te passe de couteau risque de casse
parce que ça bouge plus d'aplomb
poussière qui en tirent plutôt bien mais
tu as toujours l'ergonomie du physique
bien qu'adapté ok donc à palin non
la limite c'est ce que tu peux imaginer
penser comme l'utilisation on les
cherche
écoute c'est vachement bien
félicitations merci beaucoup et du coup
donc on se trouve à camp nou la
prochaine fois à bientôt j'espère par
les fans de paris
je veux qu'ils me parlent un peu de
la taille savoir si on grialou j'ai
l'air d'une attaque ou pomme c
ouais jamoigne avoir la faute au nord
par la banquise
merci beaucoup merci à toi merci
d'écouter supérieur continue avec ça
parce que je me sens vraiment
intéressant une boîte française qui se
positionne sur un truc comme ça c'est
vraiment incroyable l'haptique une
famille proscrite dans l'automobile
c'est génial dans le smartphone on voit
que sa source est pas encore là mais
potentiellement ça pourrait arriver
parce quand on s'est rencontré il ya
deux ans voyez les retouches et envoyer
un peu et on n'arrivait pas trop à se
projeter l'année dernière vous commencez
un parent avec l'automobile sans ce soir
encore vraiment concret la cls 2020 ses
confrères savez-vous donc on va rentrer
dedans
peut-être causé s2000 21 ou peut-être
ailleurs dit si elle ne pourra pas à lui
la vie va tech pour avancer ils ont été
implémentées dans du smartphone dont
applique avant ça apple en parle de plus
en plus dans ses téléphones alors c'est
quoi la même version nous c'est un peu
moins avancés mais avec leurs boutons
leur peut-être contrôle ou habits
développe même la boutique donc on voit
que le marché se sensibilisent génial ok
merci à toi merci à toi tout
[Musique]
malin